JENNY BROWN: Back to basics
for "Cloud Storage Bytes"
means back to buckets.
In this episode,
we'll take a look
at how different
types of buckets
impact your performance.
We'll bust some myths and
optimize our storage, just
like old times.
Something we hear a
lot on "Storage Bytes"
is, what type of
bucket should I be
using for the best performance?
And as we've
discussed previously,
Cloud Storage has a few
different bucket options.
But when talking
quick retrieval,
we're going to focus on
multi-regional and regional
buckets.
For a quick refresh
of what that means,
a regional cloud storage
bucket guarantees
that all data in that
bucket lies in a specified
region, which is really
important in situations
where you know where your client
or on-prem systems are located
and you want to get
your GCS buckets
as close to those client
systems as possible.
Multi-regional storage,
on the other hand,
guarantees two replicas of
your data which are geodiverse.
That means they're a
minimum of 100 miles apart.
This may result in
data being moved
between regions for better
latency and availability.
More importantly,
multi-regional buckets
heavily leverage edge caching
and CDNs to provide the content
to end users.
To illustrate some
real life scenarios
and better understand how these
systems respond under stress,
we'll set up a test.
Upload a 2 megabyte file
to a bunch of regional
and multi-regional buckets,
and then fetch that asset--
with caching disabled--
from a VM in us-west1.
We've got a few
different takeaways here.
Firstly, fetches
in the same region,
or in a sub region
of the multi-region,
perform pretty solidly,
just as we would expect.
But when you're
fetching from a region
noticeably far
from where you are,
you really do notice the
drop in response time.
And this is where
multi-regional buckets shine.
By duplicating that data
to a geodiverse region,
there is now a second
instance that's
likely to be much closer
to the final destination.
You see that the latency
drops, and often it's
pretty significant.
The biggest takeaway
here is that there's
no specific
performance difference
for the classification of
the buckets themselves.
The performance is dominated
by the latency and physical
distance between the client
and the cloud storage bucket.
Practically applied, we can
conclude that if caching is on
and your access volume is high
enough to take advantage of it,
there's not a huge
difference between the two
offerings due to Google's
powerful CDN environment.
If caching is off or if the
access volume is low enough
that you can't take
advantage of it,
then performance overhead is
dominated primarily by physics.
You should really aim to get the
assets as close to the clients
as possible, trading off for
your data's needs around cost,
redundancy, and consistency.
There's plenty more to come
about optimizing performance,
but we're going
to do you a favor
and save that for
another episode.
If you'd like to know more,
go ahead and check out
the links in the description.
And don't forget to subscribe,
give us a like, and as always,
tell us what you want to learn
about Google Cloud Storage.
Thank you for joining us
for this quick byte of Cloud
Storage.
See you next time.